(audience clapping)
- Hey everybody, how we doing?
Thanks so much for coming to my session,
"RAG is dead:
Long live intelligent
retrieval-augmented generation."
We gather here today to
discuss the types of situations
that unfortunately can slay RAG
and what agentic retrieval can do
to help solve this problem.
Today we'll talk about
recommendation systems,
what agentic RAG is,
and different contributions
that agentic RAG can make
in order to solve these
sorts of difficult queries.
But before we get into any of that,
I want you all to take a second
and think about this problem with me.
So imagine you're building a tech startup,
which I imagine is not too difficult
to imagine from very many of you,
and you're trying to build
a recommendation service
for restaurants and dishes,
a really popular one.
And over time you notice
that there's this really
sticky group of people
that come back to use your system,
but they don't seem to
actually enjoy it that much.
And it's couples that are
going on a first date.
And you realize that these couples
tend to have user queries in your system.
And what they really want is a
set of dishes and restaurants
that they can go to that aligns with that.
So you might have a situation
where you have person one,
they might have some restrictions,
like they need to avoid
dairy, they only eat chicken,
and they prefer eating spicy food.
And you'll have the second
person in the relationship
which might love fish and beef,
value a romantic atmosphere,
and they have a lot of
specific food allergies.
So it's really important
to find the best restaurant for them.
So you do some user studies,
you sit down with these couples,
and you realize that the
conversation goes back and forth.
People kind of think about
what they're looking for,
and they eventually land on
maybe something like the following phrase.
"We need date night restaurants
within our budget near us
that have vegetarian non-dairy
options, spicy options,
maybe a good charitable dessert
with a romantic vibe, blah, blah blah."
A really complicated set of preferences.
Now at this point you might
be thinking, alright, Arjun,
I was with you on the
recommendation system part,
but I'm not with you on this
oddly specific scenario.
This seems too arbitrary, right?
I mean, how many of you
have tried to figure out
where to eat with your significant other?
It gets pretty complicated pretty quickly.
And so you might be
thinking this is not real.
And I'm here to tell you
that this is absolutely real,
because almost six
years to this exact day,
I was agonizing over exactly what to do
in this exact situation,
because I was trying to
impress a beautiful girl
and I had to figure out
exactly where we need to go.
And it turns out that those
were our real preferences
that I had to figure out to
find the actual restaurant
for our first date.
And it worked, six years later
I proposed earlier this year.
So yes, this is a real
problem that people face.
These are types of queries
that people will have to deal
with in specific situations
with restaurant recommendations
being one of them.
And what's sticky about this
is that if we were to
use a system like this
and it gave you a poor recommendation,
the consequences are huge.
So you really just get one
shot to get this right.
Now, let's think a little harder
about what makes this
problem so difficult.
There are four distinct issues
with this type of situation.
Number one, there are a lot
of distinct data sources
that you have to reconcile
that your system needs
to be able to deal with.
And having a lot of distinct
data sources is difficult
for a retrieval-augmented
generation system to resolve.
You need to look at restaurant
reviews, descriptions,
dishes, images, what people are saying,
where these restaurants are,
any dietary restrictions
associated with those dishes.
Just thinking about how
to maintain the context
around all of those
data sources is a pain.
The second issue is that it's a high risk,
high reward situation.
If your primary demographic
is people who haven't used
your application before
and they're looking for a
really good recommendation
the first time they
interact with your system,
you better believe you serve
them a good recommendation.
And in this situation, there
are three consequences.
First, you're trying to
acquire this couple this user
for the entirety of their journey.
So they keep coming
back to your application
to get those good
restaurant recommendations.
Second, the restaurant
that's going to be serving
those recommendations
is gonna gain two seats instead of one.
So it's really important for
them to be aligned to the users
that are interested for
what they need to be doing.
And finally, the couple cares, right?
You wanna go to a place that's
gonna have really good food.
The third issue is that we're dealing
with really complicated
natural language queries.
If you were to throw this query
at a traditional vanilla RAG system,
it would absolutely fail,
because usually there is not
a query understanding portion
built into that retrieval.
Specifically, the query is long,
requires a lot of reasoning capabilities
to understand the
motivation behind the query,
and it requires planning and coordination
to solve the relevant recommendations.
Finally, because this
query is so complicated,
RAG approaches will just fail
and we need a lot more engineering work
to solve this problem.
If only we had like a set of magical boxes
that could help us parts
and understand what
these queries are doing,
wouldn't that be kind of wonderful?
Well, it turns out that
if we use agentic RAG,
we can address the complexity
of these different types
of complicated queries
through flexibility.
And in this talk, I'm gonna
go over a few techniques
in order to do that,
specifically with retrieval and databases.
The contributions that
agentic RAG can make
are the following,
first is query understanding.
In other words, we're
gonna ask the question,
how can we interpret what
the user actually needs?
And then serve recommendations
under that context.
Second, we can optimize
retrieval patterns even further.
If we know what they need,
how do we retrieve the best context given
for that information?
Finally, with the agentic RAG
we have the ability to
do iterative generation,
so we don't have to stop
at the first retrieval.
Once we have the best context,
how do we generate the best response?
The primary architecture
we're gonna be talking about
in this talk,
is gonna be the tool use
workflow architecture
that is so easy to
implement with agentic RAG,
and allows you to kind of
take a stab at this problem.
So we might have some query like,
"Hey, we need to eat
somewhere near our hotel
with our budget.
I avoid dairy and meat,
but I'm fine with eggs.
I love spicy food and it's date night.
So we need shareable plates."
This is a real thing I've
said in real life, by the way.
So an agent might take that query,
it might have access to a
set of tools and workflows,
like query transformation
procedures, criteria, evaluation,
a bunch of different databases
like our dishes, restaurants,
allergies, known allergens, and reviews,
and then serve a pattern
of recommendations.
And it's important to note
that in this architecture
the agent is deciding
what tools to use when.
So it's particularly flexible
to the types of queries
that are being passed.
Great, so let's begin
with query understanding.
Agents are able to plan
queries for optimal retrieval.
In a traditional RAG system,
you're gonna have the query
hit the database directly,
but an agent can modify the
query or add additional queries
in order to retrieve optimize context.
Here are three different
ways you can accomplish this.
The first is subquery generation,
where we ask the question,
what else could the user need
based on the query that they're asking?
The second is query routing.
This is really important
and underestimated by a lot of developers.
ie, when we have an incoming query,
where do we actually send that query
and what databases are
relevant for the user
at that given point in time?
Finally, query expansion.
If we have a given user query,
what other terms or
concepts need to be included
in order to retrieve those things?
And what constraints in
addition to those terms
and concepts do we need to be aware of?
So what does this look like in practice?
Imagine you're going to do query planning
in the context of tool use.
So we have this query I said before
which was we need to eat
somewhere near our hotel,
We have a budget, we avoid dairy and meat,
but we're fine with eggs.
I love spicy food and it's date night.
So let's do shareable plates.
The agent might intake
that query and understand
and think about what tools are relevant
in order to start parsing
and breaking this query down.
So I've put in some example tools here
that generate individual queries
that we can all pass through
their relevant databases
to retrieve context
that are then reconciled for
the ultimate recommendation.
For example, there are some
restrictions in the query here
that are relevant to what
could be inside dishes.
So I could have a tool that
parses those restrictions out
to generate those filters.
For example, food that
leans toward being spicy
or we indicate some allergies.
So we need another parsing step
that can reliably pull that
information out of the query.
There might be preferences
that are more flexible in natural language
that we can use in
criteria evaluation later,
such as no dairy, meat, or eggs,
or having family style serving.
And finally, there are
restaurant level filters
that we'll need to extract and interpret.
For example, maybe we need
something that's under $40
that has romantic atmosphere.
That information might be
inside the reviews, for example,
and that's four stars plus.
What about retrieval?
In order for agents to
work well with databases,
you need to make the databases
ergonomic for those agents,
and there are a few ways to do that.
The first is you need to put
context around the data sources
that your agents have access to.
This is probably the number one mistake
I see developers make,
where they link their
database to their agents
without properly informing
and passing schemas back to the agents
on what information is actually
contained in that database.
So you need to ask the question,
what data can the agents
access and how can it be used,
and how should the agent
use that information?
The second is the implementation
of powerful search techniques.
How do we interact with this data?
How is it stored,
and how do we use it in
order to maximize relevance?
For example, there may be
specific search techniques
that are more appropriate for
certain kinds of databases
than for others.
Finally, we should be using
filters as much as we can
in order to reduce the search
space and decrease latency.
How should we store this data
in order to reduce that latency
and time to first request?
So what does this look like?
I've created a table here
of different databases
that we could use in our application,
and how we would wanna store
and represent that data
in order to retrieve it
and make it ergonomic.
Suppose we have an index of
restaurants in this first row,
it might contain names, descriptions,
some metadata about the
restaurants like location.
We might wanna do some pre-processing,
like summarizing what
the restaurant is about
across all of the reviews.
That allows us to search
over all the restaurants
with the same exact schema,
thus resulting in standardization.
There might be some applicable filters
that are important for
our agent to know about,
like pricing, moods, location,
and it might be best to implement
a form of hybrid search,
which allows us to leverage
the semantic descriptions
that restaurants naturally have.
In addition to the keywords
that we care about,
like romantic or date night.
For dishes, we might
need a separate index,
and that index might be multimodal,
because people take photos of their food
and we care what they look like.
There might be descriptions
and linked reviews.
We might need to generate
potential ingredients
that could be missing in
order to caution users
against potential cross contamination.
And there might be allergen level filters
that we'll have to think about.
And because people really care about
what they ultimately will
eat at the restaurant,
we might need to implement some re-ranking
in order to optimize the relevancy there.
Finally, we have the review index,
which is also inherently multimodal.
People are typing their descriptions
and also putting images
of the food that's there.
We might need to implement
an image to image search
or an image to text search,
and we need to think about
how to instrument this
for our agent at hand.
Finally, we need to think about
how to improve the underlying generation.
The thing about vanilla RAG
is that very often people
will shoot out a query
to a database
and return those results
that are generated
by an LLM directly to the user.
But there's a lot of
opportunity lost there
where we could spend even more time
understanding whether
the results are relevant
to that specific user in
that specific context.
And we'll talk briefly
about some techniques
that are helpful for this situation.
First is thinking about loops
and looping your retrieval.
So what else could the user need,
and could we spend this time
and exchange latency for
some more information
that would be relevant to the user?
The second is identifying
implied preferences.
Users are notoriously bad
at describing what they want
and the first interaction
you're going to have with them.
So you need to build an architecture
that allows us to understand
what information we need to follow up with
in order to retrieve the
appropriate information.
And what of that information
is actually useful for us
in context of the data
sources we're working with.
Finally is, using structured generation.
In other words, we should
be constraining the things
that we are sending back to the user,
presenting them in
information that is helpful
for us to understand and analyze,
so that it's possible when the
user gets the recommendation.
What does that look like in practice?
For example, one of my
favorite design patterns
for implementing evaluation
in agentic retrieval is checklists.
So you might have an initial query,
such as the one we've been working with
where you have to eat somewhere.
You have a bunch of restrictions
and you can shoot that
query at your database
and orchestrate it with your agent
to retrieve all sorts of context,
such as your restaurants,
your dishes, and your reviews.
And you can pass that to the agent
with all of that context being there,
and say, hey, why don't you generate
an initial set of recommendations?
But at the same time, in parallel,
what you could do
is dynamically create
an evaluation checklist
of the criteria that you need to satisfy
in order to provide a satisfactory set
of recommended restaurants
and dishes back to the user,
as a sort of manual double checking.
Because there's a lot of querying
that happens in between the initial query
and the retrieved context,
you're gonna want something
that persists beyond that,
that evaluates against what
the agent has already generated
in order to increase the
quality of the results.
For example, it's extremely important
that we adhere to the allergens
that are described inside this query.
So it makes sense for us
to extract that as a item
in our checklist
and to evaluate the
return results at the end
of this querying workflow
against the agent
to ensure that those tests pass.
Or we wanna make sure that the restaurant
has a date night atmosphere,
so on and so forth.
Having the opportunity to
implement this additional check
at the end is really useful
for us to guarantee the
quality of the results
that we end up passing back
to the recommendation system.
And we're comfortable sacrificing
some of the latency costs here,
because of the increase in the relevancy
at the end of this workflow.
So the main takeaways
behind this architecture is,
we're able to use agentic retrieval
in areas where traditional RAG would fail
and three specific benefits.
The first is query understanding,
which is we allow for a deep planning
and reasoning capability to
decompose complex queries
and serve users that have
really complicated preferences.
The second is optimizing retrieval,
where agentic RAG allows
us to have dynamic access
to all of the data sources
which have been made ergonomic
for the agent to use,
provided that they're accessible.
And this allows us to optimize the context
that is then retrieved
for the generation step.
Finally, we implement
iterative generation,
which allows for looping
and increases the perceived quality
of the generation results.
And like I said, we're comfortable
sacrificing some of the latency costs here
in order to increase the
quality of the results,
because we care so much about making sure
that couple goes on a great first date.
Now if you wanna learn
how to build agentic RAG
and you're kind of a
little tired of the example
that I'm kind of going through,
go ahead and scan this QR code
where you can learn about how
other customers with Pinecone
have implemented agentic RAG,
such as Delphi, Aquant,
Terminal X, and CustomGPT.
This will take you straight
to the case study section
on our website
where we can learn how real customers
have implemented real architectures
implementing agentic RAG.
Thanks so much for coming to my talk.
If you have any more questions
for me about how to do this,
please meet me at the back.
I'll be happy to speak with you.
My team is at booth 534
in that corner over there,
so if you're interested
in having a more in-depth conversation,
we'd be happy to have you.
Thanks so much everybody.